>> So the normal allele makes you susceptible
to malaria, but the mutant allele deforms your red
blood cells and gives you Sickle Cell Anemia.
Neither one of those sounds like a good option.
>> It's true, but the compromise is actually having one of
each. A little resistance to malaria and minimal symptoms of anemia.
>> So being heterozygous gives you the advantage.
>> Exactly. And that's exactly what
geneticists call it. The heterozygote advantage.
>> So, we, ideally, we all want
one of each.
>> Well, it really depends on where you
live. You tell me. Which of the following
genotypes do you think would be most advantageous
if you lived in a region without malaria?